what's up everyone I'm Walter Binet
dziak I'm Heather ruse and I'm an away
and this is top five hey guys what's
your favorite kind of puppet Oh
ventriloquist dummy I've always been
partial to marionettes myself try again
okay sock puppet shadow puppets
Muppets guys are supposed to say Muppets
oh yeah not everyone saw the happy time
murders okay the Muppets have been
around for over 60 years and during that
time the brand has made an undeniable
impact on pop culture with several
movies and TV shows under their belts
these characters are well known to
several generations created in the 1950s
by Jim Henson and his wife Jane The
Muppets first broke into TV with the
local Washington DC program salmon
friends from there these unique
characters grew in popularity with
Sesame Street and perhaps their most
famous incarnation The Muppet Show this
continued success spawned their own film
series while the Muppets themselves were
purchased by Disney in 2004 since then
the Muppets have been involved in plenty
of newer projects and maintained their
immense popularity but which of these
characters have stood the test of time
the best these are the top 5 best Muppet
number 5
beaker he dresses for success and meat
down to our best beaker is dr. Bunsen
honeydew sistent
but we often see beaker as a sort of lab
rat to his companions whims he started
on the Muppet Show as a funny and
approachable way to get kids interested
in science while dr. honeydew's
experiments and in some sort of beaker
mishap beaker is a live hand puppet
meaning his puppeteers can put their
actual hands inside the puppet hands
increasing physicality and adding the
option of dexterity to pick up objects
in real time beakers constant state of
anxiety is super relatable but is also
comedy gold
his protruding nose that shakes next to
his ever open eyeballs heighten the
energy of a scene with a simple cleaver
II his dilated eyes and large downturned
mouth can make any expression funny from
a slight gaped mouth to his eyes
lighting up with electricity
even his tuft of orange hair seems in
shock but if beaker gets too overwhelmed
he activates my favorite feature tucking
his face into his shirt like a turtle a
man of few words beaker expresses his
nervous energy through a series of
high-pitched
bleeps this is interesting since his
form is one of the more human compared
to the other Muppets yet he's got a bit
of a hold or situation vocabulary wise
that doesn't stop him from singing
though
[Music]
beaker is the slaw Mazel to dr. Bunsen
honeydew seal-a-meal although it's very
fun to laugh at beaker Andy's
misfortunes he's still so lovable that
you want to see more number 4 Fozzie
Bear I'll think of a good joke just bear
with me Wacka Wacka Wacka Fozzie had his
debut on the Muppet Show
where he was the resident stand-up
comedian given the setting and story of
the Muppet Show it only made sense that
there needed to be a comedian
although fuzziest portrayed as being
pretty inept at his job often relying on
lame jokes impressions and puns he is
unfortunately heckled frequently by
Statler and Waldorf Fozzie he never lets
them discourage him from taking the
stage again even though they do
sidetrack his act and embarrass him
Kermit is his best friend
and together they play off of each other
perfectly Fozzie was originally created
to be the main character for cast member
and legend Frank oz oz was Fozzie's
principal performer for almost 25 years
his talent is one of the things that
brings his character to life and makes
him so lovable despite his flaws
personally I love his jokes and delivery
what makes it perfect is how much
confidence he has in his talent his
optimistic personality makes him
endearing he tries so hard no matter
what he pushes on because it's obvious
who loves to make people laugh and that
kind of joy is contagious
number three
animal animal is the drummer of the
house band dr. teeth and the Electric
Mayhem which first premiered on the
Muppet Show
he is also by far the most popular
member of the band having received more
screen time and merchandise than the
other members his name very much
reflects his behavior animal destroys
the drums both figuratively and
literally sometimes eating them rather
than hitting them his look and behavior
is based on many wild and crazy'
drummers what can we say percussionists
are an insane group of people it is very
rare that animal communicates in full
sentences rather he grunts and repeats
simple words or phrases it's easy to see
why people love animal he is wild and
spontaneous
I remember being enamored by him as a
child because there is a part of me that
wanted to be able to act that crazy and
free here's to you animal may you rock
on and never be tamed number 2 gonzo the
great gonzo gonzo the great this
character has been a personal favorite
of mine for years described for decades
as a whatever
gonzo species was always in question
however in Muppets from space he was
revealed to actually be an alien
whatever his origin gonzo is constantly
hilarious bizarre and always in some
sort of trouble often portrayed as a
daredevil he takes part in dangerous
stunts that sometimes don't work out the
way he thought on the Muppet Show he was
mostly just trying to get on stage and
perform an act that was as strange as he
was regardless of those performances the
character himself has been consistently
entertaining his relationship with
Camilla the chicken and friendship with
Rizzo the rat are well documented gonzo
is liked among the other Muppets
themselves and fans of the property he's
been shown as sympathetic thoughtful
weird goofy and much more but pulls off
all those characteristics effortlessly
gonzo is truly one of a kind
there are plenty more than just five
Muppets who have made a long-lasting
impression on us over the years so here
are choices for honorable mentions
[Music]
and the number one best Muppet is Kermit
the Frog yay Kermit the Frog here on top
five Walter stop you sound nothing like
Kermit
I love Kermit the Frog I don't care if
this is predictable or uninspired as our
number one choice Kermit has always been
one of my favorite characters in any
medium whenever I see him pop up it puts
a smile on my face the thing I like most
about Kermit is that he is the leader of
the Muppets but not the same type of
leader character we usually see he's
unassuming nice a good caring friend and
most of all sincere I'm not ashamed to
admit that I've shed a few tears
watching some of Kermit's best scenes
over the years his extreme likeability
makes it easy to empathize with him and
that makes this frog my favorite Muppet
Rainbow Connection alone gets him into
the top five it's a beautiful song that
tons of people can relate to
[Music]
creamer well I may not be a fan of his
taste in significant others Kermit is
the perfect straight man he's very funny
witty and smart in many of the comedic
situations he's put in it says a lot
that I can laugh cry and genuinely care
about this amphibia he's Jim Henson's
greatest creation and might even be your
favorite internet meme for more content
you can check out my review of the Power
Rangers 25th anniversary episode that
along with plenty of more videos are up
on my personal channel now we want to
hear what you guys think what's your
favorite Muppet what do you want to see
us cover next on the show leave a
comment and let us know to keep in touch
you could like my Facebook page or
follow along on Twitter and you can find
me on Facebook Twitter or Instagram and
you can find me on Twitter Instagram or
Twitter where I stream on Wednesday
nights we'll catch you right back here
next week with the worst Muppets on a
brand-new episode of top 5
[Music]
[Applause]
you
why are there so many songs about Wien
[Applause]
you